I'm mark hamill and I'm Laura Dern I'm
Daisy Ridley don't listen John boyega
holly marie Tran and we're doing the do
Jedi's get paid no they don't no they
don't did I don't get paid if they do
this to keep it balanced yeah do Jedi
build their own lightsabers well as a
matter of fact in the deleted scene that
introduced me in Return of the Jedi you
saw him building its lightsaber do
Jedi's never longer no I mean they're
involved in battle oh so thereby do you
have to be a Jedi to use a lightsaber
I'd say no no I don't think so I think
anybody can use one two Jedi have to be
celibate I think so otherwise I'd have a
girlfriend by now do you Jedi's wear
underwear I think they probably like to
just be free I'm saying that at least
boxer-briefs minds mommy do generally
choose their lightsaber colors samuel
l.jackson does he said I want a purple
one and he got one cuz he samuel
l.jackson do Jedi's Selene does anybody
say if in Star Wars uh only if they get
really hurt how do I become a Jedi
practice I can only aspire to be as good
as Luke you know I'm just pretending do
Jedi's disappear when they die of course
of course do they see what happens they
they go and return back to the force
it's like a spiritual moment for them do
Jedi use force choke I would say no but
I could be wrong every time I say
something people have read a novel or a
common move are played a video game that
proves me wrong but no that's sort of a
Darth Vader II thing so I would say no
Jedi's eat yes they did absolutely what
your favorite Star Wars character
ray easy that's not true kill it every
day yo you're supposed to say hooks oh
what's going on here what is your
favorite Star Wars Episode the one with
Hudson well yeah yeah the main one with
hooks probably what's the dog was about
what kind of people use the word is Star
Wars obey was love Star Wars about hate
star was about space what Star Wars n in
specie ah yes species are you walking
Ewok how do mark hamill Joker impression
joke crime you gotta warm up on the way
to the session so I'm driving on the
freeway going to my joke or such as
point me and of course everybody in the
freeway they take no notice it's Los
Angeles
how old is Mark Hamill in Harrison Ford
older than we ever plan to be but you
know I say the Harrison will always be
older than me but the Rolling Stones
will always be older than you I just
feel much better
Howard Mark Hamill do it I'm having the
time of my life who knew there was a
Jedi pension plan is Mark Hamill related
to Dorothy Hamill she was on the cover
of Time magazine this is a true story I
got stopped for going over the speed
limit and the policeman was about to
give me write out the ticket he saw the
magazine on the passenger's seat he goes
wait a second jørgen him I said I know I
know I get that all the time
she's the famous one in the family he
said you know what I'll just give you a
warning jah maica have a british accent
yeah I think why did John boyega have
American accent it didn't suit my accent
when I went in to go and do it it just
didn't it just didn't work out I went to
rained for it and it was a horrible
first audition I can't lie yeah but when
I did it
with the American accent which is what
yeah why does John boyega have a
lightsaber I'm asking myself that every
single day I actually personally owned
about nine right now one I do
okay why does yoga look like oh I'm
sorry jumbo you look like I'd like to
see the search results for these no no
no it's not one person yeah little do
you know this is all me this is real
hey Rey beat kylo Ren why is that so
hard for people to get like she's super
strong and he's like so weak he kicked
his ass
that's how wavy kylo Ren how Ray has the
force everyone has a force even Hux is
that true
I thought some people can have the force
and some people I need to watch the
movies again
hey Rey understands bb-8 she's vastly
intelligent our array and luke connected
by a long-ass stair at the end of force
awakens how to race to our wars hair how
to race doll was how you get wonderful
hair and makeup artists to do for ya why
Luke Skywalker hiding cuz he can why
Luke Skywalker wants the Jedi to end oh
you're gonna have to wait for a that's
why Luke Skywalker is the most powerful
Jedi why probably the process of
elimination
who's left why Luke Skywalker went into
hiding
he chose Ben solo as the chosen one and
he turned out to be tragically wrong a
lot of guilt I think Skywalker is a bad
ass kids don't use these phrases at home
maybe you think that but I don't think
he thinks that of himself why does Luke
Skywalker's lightsaber change from blue
to green oh well a blue is the one that
obi-wan gave me and I lost that one in
unfortunate amputation incident Weston a
clothes very good question
no he isn't
the the stormtroopers are not clone
troopers anymore they're stormtroopers
now right there the normal one so
they're recruited as children there
they're taken as babies and and then
brainwashed was vid died in Star Wars in
terms of that vote no I'd really just be
hanging around doing a press tour for
nervous been Star Wars Grey's Anatomy I
think maybe they're asking were you ever
on an episode of Grey's Anatomy no I
like Grey's Anatomy this I mean why
should just say yes yes hey Shonda yes
who was Ben's father Star Wars whoever
he was he was a bad parent I mean there
must have got for him to take me Wayne I
mean the first order and all that kind
of stuff sorry was Finn spelled wrong a
Jedi could he be a Jedi it's general hug
Luke son this was the thing the
banaynays the film they didn't say what
part I was playing yeah a lot of people
were coming up to me thinking that I was
playing Luke's song yeah so I think that
got mixing cuz I look a little bit like
Mack I think you don't I don't know more
like Cate Blanchett is general Hux for
sensitive this is what we were just
talking about I thought that no I
thought that I didn't think he was able
to be by if he can be everyone has that
ability it's just some people are more
in it than others right okay well then I
would say that yes is general Hawkes no
its general Hawkes at Cologne I do think
it's hilarious that they worked so hard
to create these new characters and they
liked them must they must have come from
before yeah yeah people really want them
to links to it there yeah I think so is
general Hawkes still alive first name
Armitage I know that really yes somebody
told me an interviewer told me - they
had announced that one of the books Oh
in the novelization stuff
shorty somebody should be telling me
that stuff does have siblings so Laura
Dern does not you're an only child
did one Oscar no have not have you been
nominated I have for ramblin rose oh my
gosh wild food is laura dern play in
Jurassic Park I play dr. Ellie Sattler
okay there you are a botanist order play
the flute I said that I played the flute
on The Ellen Show it was all a ruse to
give away free gifts at Christmas for
her audience
where did laura dern go to school in Los
Angeles which shall remain nameless yeah
I think it's fine the school that must
not be named who does laura dern play in
star wars finally won even I know but
you answer it well maybe you should
because you know what we're allowed to
say more than me
first of all Admiral hold O where they
come up with these names and then when I
first saw her I thought oh my god she's
got Dame Edna's hair okay who is Kelly
Marie Trang I am me next
how old is Kelly Marie Trent I'm 28 yeah
who is Kelly Marie trend Star Wars I
don't think they like to Google complete
sentences okay yeah yeah yeah but I
think they were just curious as to what
it meant to this franchise okay great
which is oh he's kidding me retrying
real nope I'll check yep is Kenny
Vietnamese yes oh nice that's what I'm
talking about
who is Rose tinkle oppa this is so crazy
she is a maintenance worker who's used
to being in the background in terms of
the resistance she's usually not on the
forefront at all and then she meets
spins for the first time and then her
life gets drastically more interesting
actually
[Laughter]